dudes i'm so excited that the wild
stallions are back together again
um most important question keanu have
your air guitar skills improved over the
past
three decades uh no i've never been very
good at
air guitar but um i you know
but i what i lack in talent i now i
probably won't even make up an
enthusiasm
but i try to give it a go okay so a
little rusty uh how about you alex
uh i figured it out i think by day
the last day or so of shooting i think i
just got figured it out
nice um alex how much fun was it for you
you know obviously working with keanu
again and being able to bring bill back
to the big screen
it was really fun we we worked really
hard to get this film off the ground
all of us and it took time and a lot of
work
and we worked very hard making the film
they're very
challenging films to make they're very
physical but
look at the end of the day when we're
just it's just the two of us or the
great ensemble we had just riffing
it's really fun they're really fun
worlds to live in
can you this movie really feels like a
love letter to the fans was that the
goal with face music
um yeah i mean in a sense i mean i i
don't think it's
you know it's i don't think we probably
never said that
sentence but yeah um
certainly you know even while we were
trying to
to make the film you know
the fan influence influence on us being
able to
make the film alex and i made a video
just thanking everyone you know um
so you know we hope people enjoy the
film and
and i know i know we talked about that a
lot
dude now did you go back and watch the
first two films to kind of get you know
the head space with getting back into
your character ted i didn't yeah not so
much i think we were both concerned with
with creating very true
versions of ourselves that were the age
that we are
and not getting caught up in trying to
replicate
you know who we were so many years ago
uh it felt like kind of a sand trap that
we wanted to avoid but you know we
certainly know the characters well and
could find the aspects of them and that
was really enjoyable
so i was obsessed with the first two
films what is it about bill and ted
that really connected with fans and
still does to this day what is that
magic between those two characters
i you know i mean there's a wonderful
friendship there i mean
there's the scripts are fun they're
warm the dialogue is great there's
a love of language the stakes are high
you know it's the ridiculous but the
people
they touch us and uh you know it's
um and they're unique you know
yeah well i've always wanted to say this
especially to you to be excellent to
each other
thanks so much guys and party on yeah
you